(Texting dings)
I was just wondering if you
wanted to um, you know, go out
sometime?
Do you want to get a coffee?
Now?
Yes, now!
I’ll just hang on.
♪When I wake up,
Well I know I'm gonna be♪
Cole:
Her name is Sadie.
♪I'm gonna be the man who wakes
up next to you♪
Cole:
I mean I know this sounds
crazy,
Cole:
but I think she might be
the one!
♪I know I'm gonna be,
I'm gonna be the man who goes
along with you♪
She really is great. You’ll see.
Man:
Any word?
She ghosted him.
I bet she isn’t even seeing your
texts.
She does travel a lot for work.
Go to her.
I’m going to London.
♪♪
♪But I would walk 500 miles♪
See, you get it. It’s a grand,
romantic gesture!
Yea, that’s amazing, mate! Five
thousand miles to surprise a
girl you’ve only met once.
Especially if she’s the one
who ghosted ya.
No, no. She didn’t ghost me. She
just doesn’t have an
international calling plan.
Oh, right.
♪♪
Where am I?
Oh, God. You have the wrong guy!
I’m a farmer. Wait, wait!
(Panics)
Can you walk, Cole?
Sadie!
Who are you?
C.I.A.
I’m so confused. They kept
asking me about the tax man.
They asked you about the tax
man?
They think I am a tax man.
You’re the tax man?
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God!
♪♪
You got me kidnapped
and tortured all after one date!
I swallowed a rock!
You’re the one who flew to
London!
It was a romantic gesture!
♪♪
Leveque:
Get every bounty hunter
on the continent.
I want her alive!
♪♪
This is bigger than you and me.
Monte:
Didn’t it ever occur to you that
he could be a foreign asset
trying to compromise your
mission?
Who the hell are you?
I’m the boyfriend.
Do you trust me?
Is that a joke?